big kim and kanye news their days as
husband and wife
are officially coming to an end
we have different views sometimes
kim filed the divorce papers today
putting an end to their six years of
marriage
we're told kim is asking for joint legal
and physical custody
of their four children kanye is fine
with that both are committed to
co-parenting
another source tells us the couple has
been done for a while and have been
amicable for a while
at the end of the day kanye and kim love
each other immensely
but knew it was time to call it quits at
the end of the day life is about being
happy
a source tells e.t kanye is upset that
it didn't work out and it will take him
some time
to adjust to his new normal the past few
months have been rough on the couple
we're told they've been living separate
lives kanye and wyoming
kim in la with the kids and kanye's
unusual behavior
has been making headlines she brought
north into the world
even when i didn't want to when you're
bipolar you have a potential to ramp up
and it can take you to a point
where you can even end up in a hospital
our source says there is a prenup and
neither kim nor kanye
is planning to contest it according to
forbes together kim and kanye are worth
more than two billion dollars kim's
well-known divorce attorney
laura wasser told us friday filings like
this
are part of her strategy she also did it
for clients like khloe kardashian
anna ferris and heidi klum the
courthouse closes at
los angeles superior court at 4 30. we
will usually send somebody down there
right before the end of the day
rather than on a monday where you're
hearing about it for the entire week
you